françois bayrou premiers invités de
cette édition spéciale
bonsoir monsieur bayrou c'est un abus de
faiblesse pour le gouvernement valls oui
en tout cas c'est la certitude désormais
qu'il n'y a pas de majorité pour
conduire la politique que le
gouvernement valls préconise qu'on se
trouve devant une rupture à l'intérieur
de la gauche entre les réformistes ceux
qui veulent que change les choses qu'il
faut absolument changer et les jusqu'au
boutistes ceux qui voudraient que rien
ne change au contraire qu'on revienne en
arrière sur un certain nombre de
problèmes que le pays rencontre est donc
cette fracture qui existe en réalité
depuis le début depuis depuis l'élection
aujourd'hui elle est béante l état qu
elle s'accuse et tout ça va va poser un
problème très lourd au gouvernement et
ya pire encore c'est que ça empêche la
politique que dont la france a besoin de
se faire parce qu'après tout qu'ils
aient des difficultés au sein du parti
socialiste de la majorité ou de la
gauche c'est assez peu important mais
que au bout du chemin on soit incapable
de faire passer les textes qui s'impose
ça c'est un vrai souci parce que le 49-3
qui a été adoptée qui a été appliqué
aujourd'hui il ne peut servir qu'une
seule fois par session parlementaire
donc les autres textes seront à empêcher
de passer c'est un un vrai et graves
soucis
bon en même temps on peut imaginer que
cette loi macron sera finalement adoptée
puisque rappelons le avec le 49-3 on ne
demande plus aux députés de voter sur
une loi mais de soutenir ou non au
gouvernement on voit mal les frondeurs
socialiste voté cette motion de censure
le 49 3 est prévue par la constitution
de la vème république ça a déjà été
utilisé plusieurs fois michel rocard par
exemple en son temps l'avait utilisé 28
fois parce qu'à l'époque qu'il avait une
majorité relative est ce qu'on n'est pas
en train de dramatiser finalement une
procédure qui est prévu par la
constitution et que la droite et la
gauche ont déjà utilisé
non je pense que vous avez raison que
c'est prévu par la constitution
et personne ne dit que c'est
inconstitutionnel simplement c'est une
procédure qui est fait pour faire plier
ceux qui sont en désaccord à l'intérieur
du camp de la majorité en leur disant si
vous ne publiez pas jeudi sous de
l'assemblée et vous le voyez bien c'est
une épreuve de force ça prouve qu'il
n'ya plus d'adhésions qu'il n'y a plus
de soutien à l'intérieur de la majorité
et même dans l'ensemble de l'assemblée
pour la politique du gouvernement et
comme je vous le disais c'est le sait le
l'urgence de des réformes nécessaires
qui se trouve compromise moi je pense
que ceci doit être un grave sujet de
préoccupation pour tous ceux qui
s'intéressent au redressement du pays
attendez il reste deux ans pour françois
hollande deux ans des quinquennats que
va-t-il se passer selon vous à moi je
pense que cette fracture va continuer à
s'élargir et qu'il faudra qu'un jour ou
l'autre le président de la république
s'interroge sur la manière de sortir de
cette impasse parce que c'est son action
qui va être bloquée sentir de l'impasse
c'est d'ouvrir la majorité peut-être
vous demandez à vous d'entrer dans le
gouvernement
je crois pas du tout que les solutions
de bricolage ou les où les solutions de
deux roues de secours puissent avoir le
moindre intérêt le la situation est
telle que nous avons des institutions et
des règles électorales qui sont
aujourd'hui complètement dépassés qui
laisse peut-être 50 % des français en
dehors de la représentation si vous
ajoutez l'extrême droite extrême gauche
ou le centre ce sont des familles
politiques qui bien qu'étant soutenu par
des millions de français n'ont pas leur
place on peut être en désaccord grave
avec ces familles mais elles n'ont pas
leur place tout ceci est un jeu
politique qui ne ressemble pas au pays
françois bayrou je voudrais également
vous interroger sur l'autre information
principale de la journée à savoir
l'annulation de l'arbitrage tapie par la
cour d'appel de
harry l'arbitrage controversé qui
rappelons le avait accordé 403 millions
d'euros à bernard tapie en 2008 pour
solder son vieux litige avec le crédit
lyonnais
45 millions pour le préjudice moral
parmi ses 400 3 millions et vous avez
été l'un des premiers à dénoncer cet
arbitrage
j'imagine votre satisfaction ce soir au
sait même pas de la satisfait de la
satisfaction personnelle ça n'est pas un
combat personnel
mais ce peu nombreux qui depuis le début
on dit attention cette affaire est
insupportable parce qu'elle est d'une
part vraiment extrêmement étrange et on
a l'impression qu'il y a eu des
interventions mystérieuse diverses et
variées et que les que ça a été un
arbitrage déloyale et d'autre part que
le recours à cette procédure est est
illégale
ceux là ont aujourd'hui trouvé dans une
décision sans précédent
une décision sans précédent pour une
affaire sans précédent il faut dire dans
cette décision sans précédent ce qui se
sont battus trouve en effet le enfin une
décision de justice qui dit à quel point
tout ça était inacceptable
et quand vous pensez à tout ce qu'il a
fallu faire pour en arriver là
alors vous vous dites que oui en effet
il y avait bien des sujets qui méritait
d'être souligné dans cette période et
dans cette affaire bernard tapie doit
rembourser immédiatement cet argent son
avocat dit qu'il n'est pas obligé de le
faire ce n'est pas dans l'arène la cour
d'appel c'est vrai que c'est pas dans
l'arrêt de la cour d'appel c'est dans la
logique de la décision mais je fais
confiance à tous à toutes les les
procédures lancées par des procéduriers
pour qu'on retarde au maximum possible
la conclusion qui serait logique qui
serait de rendre l'argent mais l'argent
existe-t-il encore où est il
vous avez dans cette affaire beaucoup de
points d'interrogation ce qui est
frappant pour moi c'est que tout ceci a
été conduit par l'état alors que c'était
illégal
d'habitude bas il ya toujours des des
personnes qui veulent faire de l'argent
avec des affaires diverses et variées ça
n'est pas neuf y en a toujours eu sous
la république mais d'habitude l'état le
le gouvernement la république sont du
côté de ceux qui essaient d'empêcher ces
ces dérives et là dans cette affaire-là
ce qui est frappant c'est que l'état a
été du côté de ceux qui organisaient ce
trucage et qui ont spolié les français
de 400 millions d'euros je ne sais pas
si vous voyez ce que ça veut dire
et si vous voyez ce que signifie un
préjudice moral de 45 millions alors que
hélas pour un drame épouvantable comme
la mort d'un enfant le préjudice moral
et de 30000 et donc c'est on a donné
mille cinq cents fois plus pour des
affaires entre guillemets financière
dont on sait aujourd'hui tu en réalité
elle n'avait pas lieu d'être
et c'est ça qui est particulièrement
frappant alors qu'il y ait une justice
en france même si c'est des années des
années après même s'il a fallu se battre
et parfois seul pour tout ce qu'ils ont
dit écoutez ça n'est pas normal on va
pas laisser faire de ce point de vue là
on a au fond un sentiment civique un
sentiment de citoyens qui se dit que bon
un pas a été fait dans le sens de la
justice
merci françois bayrou